wow you know they have been helping our
community with affordable housing
financial literacy for 30 years the need
is great and it's year round but right
now Neighborhood Housing Services of
Southern Nevada is asking for your help
to give families a nice holiday and
offering some help to those who are in
need so joining me this morning CEO and
president Michelle Merced and Tiffany
Webb board member ladies first thanks
for waking up early to come on the show
thank you for helping us this is a big
event Winter Wonderland is coming up
next Saturday the 17th before we talk
about the event a lot of folks even
though you've been here 30 years may not
know what nhssn is so Michelle give us
an example of what you guys do So
currently Neighborhood Housing Services
of Southern Nevada has almost 160 units
that are scattered across the valley I
always say that we're the first look to
our partnering non-profits who don't
have real estate and so they focus on
the Supportive Services and we focus on
making sure that they have a safe place
to call home on top of we provide home
buyer education down payment assistance
pre-purchase counseling and if anybody's
facing foreclosure we also do that on
top of all these grassroot events that
we're doing Winter Wonderland 3.0 is
coming up third year in a row that we
studied during the pandemic and so we're
super excited just to help out in every
which way just any way you can any way
we can we know the need is great Tiffany
you're the The Mastermind behind this
big event on Saturday the 17th at Orr
Middle School correct correct so it's
going to be a drive-through talk to
people like let's say they're sitting at
home and they want to know hey what can
I donate how can I help what do you need
we need 300 plus blankets 300 plus
trees 300 plus 25 gift cards from
anywhere doesn't matter okay so Target
Smith whatever Walmart doesn't matter it
doesn't matter okay
um it's about the feel good we want to
give back to the community we're going
to give back to families who are maybe
struggling right now need that extra
help so we are here for them we're going
to have two Santa Clauses two Santa
Clauses okay Santa's
um an elf Governor sicilak he will be
attending wonderful and we're going to
have more dignitaries as well that's
going to be out there now this is a
drive-through event and you know it
started during covid which made perfect
sense but this is a great way so
families they're going to kind of pull
into the school and and if they need
help all they have to do is drive
through and and you guys in Santa and
everyone and I know I'm me and my
husband are going to be out there to
help us yes okay you're going to drive
through we're going to place the food in
your vehicles we're not turning anyone
away if you do not have a vehicle you
can drive I mean walk up okay and with a
basket a cart whatever you have and
we're going to put food in there great
we're not turning anyone away and you
partnered with the just one project for
this so there'll be some hams and and
things for people so not only gifts for
the season but also some some things to
eat for the holidays absolutely great
event so Winter Wonderland 3.0 as it's
the third year
um and and I wish we had more time to
talk more about this event so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to tell
everybody go to the website for nhss and
you can see everything they do Michelle
you have an incredible organization
doing such good I know you have a lot of
people you'd like to thank yes first
definitely my team my community building
engagement my board I definitely want to
say thank you to just one American
Public Works Association Grand Canyon
development Simmons group LP Insurance
Credit One Bank red panda and Air Supply
Incorporated because they've actually
come through in the infant stages to
make sure that this is going to be
successful event so thank you so much it
takes a village everybody at home you
know that so anything you can do get in
touch with these ladies drop off
donations a couple different spots in
town but also at nhfsn so come see us
next Saturday at the event ladies thank
you